hey folks I've got a relatively quick
video for you today just sort of a
footnote between chapters in the last
two videos I talked about linear
transformations and matrices but I only
showed the specific case of
transformations that take two
dimensional vectors to other
two-dimensional vectors in general
throughout the series we'll work mainly
in two dimensions mostly because it's
easier to actually see on the screen and
wrap your mind around but more
importantly than that once you get all
the core ideas in two dimensions they
carryover pretty seamlessly to higher
dimensions nevertheless it's good to
peek our heads outside a flatland now
and then to you know see what it means
to apply these ideas in more than just
those two dimensions for example
consider a linear transformation with
three dimensional vectors as inputs and
three-dimensional vectors as outputs we
can visualize this by smashing around
all the points in three-dimensional
space as represented by a grid in such a
way that keeps the gridlines parallel
and evenly spaced and which fixes the
origin in place and just as with two
dimensions every point of space that we
see moving around is really just a proxy
for a vector who has its tip at that
point and what we're really doing is
thinking about input vectors moving over
to their corresponding outputs and just
as with two dimensions one of these
transformations is completely described
by where the basis vectors go but now
there are three standard basis vectors
that we typically use the unit vector in
the X Direction I hat the unit vector in
the Y Direction J hat and a new guy the
unit vector in the Z Direction called K
hat in fact I think it's easier to think
about these transformations by only
following those basis vectors since the
full 3d grid representing all points can
get kind of messy by leaving a copy of
the original axes in the background we
can think about the coordinates of where
each of these three basis vectors lands
record the coordinates of these three
vectors as the columns of a 3x3 matrix
this gives a matrix that completely
describes the transformation using only
nine numbers
as a simple example consider the
transformation that rotates space 90
degrees around the y axis so that would
mean that it takes I hat to the
coordinates 0 0 negative 1 on the z axis
it doesn't move J hat so it stays at the
coordinates 0 1 0 and then k hat moves
over to the x axis at 1 0 0
those three sets of coordinates become
the columns of a matrix that describes
that rotation transformation
to see a wear vector with coordinates
XYZ lands the reasoning is almost
identical to what it was for two
dimensions each of those coordinates can
be thought of as instructions for how to
scale each basis vector so that they add
together to get your vector
and the important part just like the 2d
case is that this scaling and adding
process works both before and after the
transformation
so to see where your vector lands you
multiply those coordinates by the
corresponding columns of the matrix and
then you add together the three results
multiplying two matrices is also similar
whenever you see two 3x3 matrices
getting multiplied together you should
imagine first applying the
transformation encoded by the right one
then applying the transformation encoded
by the left one it turns out that 3d
matrix multiplication is actually pretty
important for fields like computer
graphics and robotics since things like
rotations in three dimensions can be
pretty hard to describe but they're
easier to wrap your mind around if you
can break them down as the composition
of separate easier to think about
rotations
performing this matrix multiplication
numerically is once again pretty similar
to the 2-dimensional case in fact a good
way to test your understanding of the
last video would be to try to reason
through what specifically this matrix
multiplication should look like thinking
closely about how it relates to the idea
of applying two successive
transformations in space
[Music]
in the next video I'll start getting
into the determinants
you